nobody knows the system better than me
which is why I alone can fix it to a lot
of people
Trump's acceptance speech sounded like
straight-up authoritarian is and as a
matter of fact social science has found
a link between Trump supporters and
authoritarian beliefs but is the
Democratic Party the antidote we asked
delegates in Philadelphia on the first
day of the Democratic National
Convention
did you watch Donald Trump's speech at
the Republican National Convention yes
what was your reaction well he made a
lot of Mussolini faces I wish that were
a joke it isn't speaking of Mussolini
do you believe Trump is an authoritarian
he has most of the blueprint or
lieutenants of that yes people have felt
that he sounded authoritarian like some
authoritarian strongman do you get that
impression
he's one of those people who believe
that he can fix all the world's problems
without having anyone else ate him
I don't you Donald Trump as a consensus
maker I hear him thinking I can do it
and the only one can do it do you think
that Donald Trump respects democracy in
the Constitution and the process I do
think he does respect those lines but I
think that he when the opportunity
arises will stretch the lines
I don't feel he respects the
Constitution or the presidential power
you think that Democrats offer a viable
anti-authoritarian alternative yeah
definitely I believe that Secretary
Clinton is someone who is very much
willing to hear other people's concerns
and work with the right people to get
those issues address free speech is an
anti-authoritarian value you
yes I am first free speech and what
about the role of government in policing
you know hate speech well it depends it
depends on what the hate speech looks
like whether free speech should have any
limitations and I think that we need to
educate people more about what is the
proper way to use their voice citizens
united case was about a political film
and anti-hillary political documentary
the courts ruled that that was free
speech you disagree with that yes do you
believe in free trade across borders
depends I'm for fair trade myself what
do you mean by that for fair trade I you
know we have to look at if it's free
trade you know it could be disparaging
for certain people
Democrats have banned air B&B in certain
cities how do you feel about
the Democrat approach to sharing it
Nanami yeah I think that they're trying
to put push forth very progressive
values that are going to definitely
spread the wealth and provide people
like young people like me and that's the
Democrats respect the the democracy and
the democratic process more than someone
like Donald Trump might yes Hillary
Clinton has said if she is elected and
Congress won't act on guns that she will
take some sort of administrative action
to regulate guns do you agree with that
even though it kind of circumvents the
legislative process if Congress doesn't
want to work with the public then that
is her right as president and she is
representing all of us one of the
unprecedented things in foreign policy
for the Obama administration was the
executive signing off on drone hits one
person at the top making the calls do
you think Hillary is the right person to
be doing that and that she should be
doing that I definitely believe so I
believe that we have a president of the
United States and it's a voted position
so we can have someone to take the
executive powers at me she was Secretary
of State under the Obama administration
and there were several overseas
interventions that happened without
congressional approval Libya Yemen and
Pakistan to name a few so you're okay
with the president having
and a powered act kinda unilaterally and
overseas interventions what is the
safety of our of our country and it's
it's it's a threat to our country I feel
the president has as the constitutional
right to do that
some cases when you're talking about a
situation of crisis there are means
where you need to take action for it to
prevent something even worse from
occurring Democrats have proposed
putting punitive taxes on corporations
that try to leave Chuck Schumer even
tried to propose a punishment for the
former Facebook founder when he left to
go live in Singapore companies need to
understand that they can't just they
have to be loyal to the public to their
workers how do you feel about Edward
Snowden and her position on them you
should be in prison is such a divisive
subject that it needs to be contained
even though he exposed possibly
unconstitutional surveillance from an
unaccountable agency on the American
public I really don't have a comment on
it because I'm not too versed in it but
I know that she would do what she thinks
is best for the country in the safety
for the country we will make America
safe again